And the answer is 0.523, 52.3%
To see this, first, recognize that these two sequences have the same probability.
The probability with a fair coin of this sequence is 0.125,
whereas with our loaded coin, the probability is 0.081.
So, the probability of either of these sequences of flips is 12.5% if the coin is fair
and only 8.1% if the coin is loaded.
So, to figure out the probability that the coin is fair, we'll just use Bayes' Rule.
Note that the 0.5 simply represents that there's an equal or 50%
chance of having coin 1 versus coin 2.
And this expression equals 0.6080 and so the probability that we have the same coin is simply
the probability that we both have type 1 or fair coins, plus the probability of
my having coin 2 times the probability of your having coin 2.
And since the probabilities are the same, since the underlying probabilities were the same for each flip,
we have 0.608² plus (1-0.608)² and evaluating this expression gives us our answer.